chéri vous pouvez me poser toutes les
questions vous laisser dans la lumière
est cette fois s'est jamais gêné vous
répondez art si vous répondez mal ou si
vous mentez à vos chroniques attention
la caso bas alors des bars puisqu'on a
vu la fameuse enquête débat vous dis
toujours que vous ne découvrez les
images que à l'antenne oui quel est
votre degré d'intervention dans nos
chroniques dans ce qu'on peut
transmettre à la prod chaque jour
qu'est-ce que vous avez pas mentir 00
parfois formés 0 jamais vérifié 0 un but
d'arnaud n'est pas un terme aux ipad
intéresse mais rien de précis alors vous
avez comme si vous travaillez vous dites
vous dit un petit mot sur la saison et
vous me posez une question beinheim à
moi j'aimerais dire un petit mot sur sur
sur vous non il sera sur son voile a
surnommé sur voila moi je vais
franchement dire sur la vie sur vous
deux sur nous deux sur eux ce qui vous
arrive non parce que vous savez très
bien chez resserrer les liens qui nous
unissent et je voulais non mais je
voulais en profiter de déguiser mais non
mais de ce petit moment un peu
l'ensemble en thèse ou des paquets leur
dire non mais pour vous dire à quel
point je veux trouve un garçon
formidable est un garçon droit non très
sincèrement parce que ya évidemment le
pô le patron le producteur que je trouve
brillant et puis à l'homme qui est mon
ami mais mon frère est vraiment laid qui
a toujours été mathieu a parlé hier de
deux personnalités qui sont rarement les
mêmes et avec qui sur qui on peut
compter
nous on sait tous ici moi je pense
parler au nom de mes camarades qu'on
peut compter sur vous en dehors de la
mission
[Applaudissements]
c'est une passion de c'est une façon de
te dire que je t'aime moi aussi je
t'aime fort mais je crois que ceux déjà
signés
alors là que ma question est la suivante
on a traversé quelques petites
polémiques l'année dernière et donc je
voulais savoir comment est ce que vous
aviez comment ce que tu avais démarrer
la saison
est-ce que tu étais un peu stressé
angoissé est ce que tu voulais entre
guillemets démarrer différemment et
comment est ce que justement tu fais le
bilan de cette saison
alors non non non on a on a eu c'est
vrai qu'on a eu des polémiques l'an
dernier on est arrivé on était tous très
contents de se retrouver mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu voilà on était tous un peu
savaient pas si on devait déconnez pas
déconner ça a bien marché secondaire à
aa se lancer et c'est vrai qu'on a voilà
je vous ai dis juste un truc et il faut
juste faire une bonne émission et vous
inquiétez pas tout se passera bien
mais c'est vrai qu'on était un petit peu
stressé cette saison plus que les autres
années parce que vous voulez changer
beaucoup de choses et en fait après on
est revenu on sait faire voilà ce qu'on
aime faire donc c'est vrai qu'au départ
voilà on tâtonnait un peu et c'est vrai
que la première émission que vous verrez
demain puis ce contrat-là sur le prime
on viendra aussi sur tout ce qui s'est
passé cette année n'a rien à voir avec
l'émission de ce soir mais je préfère
nettement l'émission tout ça voilà donc
michael merci d'être là au 6 juin
alors c'est bon les filles vous avez vos
adorateurs vous avez vos détracteurs
pour moi vous êtes la rock star du paf
vous observent depuis deux ans et
j'allais dire que ces espaces de liberté
absolument dingue pour pour moi et pour
nous tous je suis absolument jamais
d'accord avec vous mais j'aime votre
mauvais goût j'aime vos colères non mais
c'est ça qui est bien c'est alors plus
on est plutôt bien d'ailleurs
mais vous voulez finalement qu'on
s'exprime et je trouve que c'est
extrêmement précieux extrêmement rare
tous les soirs deux heures à la
télévision et donc je vous en remercie
et moi c'est une expérience absolument
inoubliable et fabuleuse pour moi on
reste avec nous l'an prochain mais
j'espère instant rien ici bien sûr que
je veux pour acheter avec j'aime votre
mauvaise ou spams à la merci vous avez
une question posée oui je vais savoir
l'année a été un peu compliqué un peu
conflictuelle entre yann barthès et vous
il veut savoir quels étaient vos liens
aujourd'hui votre relation avec lui je
parle pas du tout nîmes a des chances de
sms pas de vous devez tout dire vous
êtes sur le ferai dès la vérité j'ai dû
l'envoyer de trois sms
ouais mais cinq ans n'a jamais rêvé
qu'il n'apparaît pas de répondre aux
normes d pad et les chics amener des
réponses mais il m'a jamais répondu
voilà donc on se parle pas du tout mais
car voilà c'est chacun pour soi trail
chacun chez soi et démons
bien gardé oui gêné parce que ses
ouailles et oui alors moi la séquence
émotion la frappe de même parce que deux
jours de suite ça va être trop donc là
je le devais me concentrer
ap le conducteur autres alors oui
l'émission se veut rassurant faits
concrets mais qui est lié sait les
audiences que c'est mon boulot s'il a
regardé mois à airtel puisque ici encore
et donc les orientent depuis janvier
elles sont constamment en tête les
autres ils sont pas plus cons que moi
ils les regardent aussi dans les autres
chaînes
est-ce que du coup ils nous ont
davantage contacter que que l'année
dernière par exemple est ce qu'ils on
vous en fait des propositions plus ou
moins concrètes dans les autres chaînes
non mais je vais vous dire déjà tf1
ouais parce qu'il tenait à toronto
il sent pas maso franchement il n'ya
aucune chaîne qui m'a appelé je vous
dire tout le monde sait que je suis je
suis ici pour moi
[Applaudissements]
en pleine consécutive la comptable a
battu le record du monde 37 à faire ça
non mais dont on encore meilleur mais
c'est vrai qu'ici voilà je suis ils
m'imaginent pas partir de ces vite c'est
vrai que j'ai de très bons rapports avec
m6 et que si un jour je le dis toujours
si un jour je dois partir de ces mythes
ou voilà du groupe canal+
voilà ce serait pour aller dans le
groupe m6 est vite ça ce serait trop
vieille avec plaisir j'ai dit oui tony
alors moi je vous les connaissiez pas là
j'ai passé une super saison avec vous je
suis ravi d'avoir fait que tutoyer
alors fais ta rencontre au mans pour moi
c'était génial je vécus des rêves j'ai
vécu des dards cas de ouf et d'amour
et voilà moi je voulais vraiment
souligner parce que depuis début tu m'a
accompagné tu m'a conseillé tu m'as tu
m'avais très bons conseils et c'est
grâce à ça que j'étais à l'aise dès le
début voilà je vais t'en remercier ma
mère si t'es sympa si j'ai une petite
question je voulais savoir qu'est-ce qui
pourrait te faire arrêter la télé pu
voir ta gueule c'est pas tout vouloir
vous dire non non non franchement si si
pour l'instant on s'amuse tellement
l'année dernière on a eu tellement de
polémiques tellement de gens qui nous
chercher des poux dans la tête je me
suis posé la question d'arrêter et
d'être un moment où est de passer et
d'arrêter tous d'accord d'arrêter de
faire du tennis faire d'aller voir les
gens voilà qui fait avec eux faire des
baby foot dans des bars tout ça voilà
normalement je me suis posé la question
mais cette année plus voilà plus
franchement
mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment je me
suis posé la question peut-être
d'arrêter l'année dernière mais là cette
année plus tôt mathieu alors moi j'aime
pas trop si c'est préventif inédit qui
démarre cet exercice facture se croiser
monsieur méritait pas du cachemire je
pense que c'est depuis je sais pas peut
décider en quoi ma plus belle année pour
moi après je dis que je parle pour moi
ce que j'ai ressenti moi parce que comme
amanda lear je ne suis bon à l'antenne
que si on même est là pour être très
sérieux cette année tu m'a beaucoup
donné et donc j'ai pu sans doute mais
aussi non mais tu fais ce que je veux
dire cette année je me suis senti aimé
voilà j'ai donc ça s'est très bien passé
tant qu'elle peut rien faire et puisque
je vais dire aussi c'est qu'elle est ce
qu'on voit à l'antenne ce qu'ont les
bêtises qu'on fait mais est ce cas hors
antenne et hors antenne moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup touché c'est que quand j'étais
à peu un gala pour signer des pros de
des machins le premier qui prenait son
téléphone et qui négocient pour moi
c'était toi quand je me casse la gueule
en scooter va le premier qui vient et
qui me dit dans trois secondes chez dans
l'ambulance et qui me tient la main
quand je suis en larmes parce que j'ai
une minerve je ne sais pas si je vais ce
qui va m'arriver parce que ça m'a fait
peur bah c'est toi quand même quand il
ya un connard qui m'agresse ou qu'ils
m'insultent sur twitter au téléphone
dans la seconde en jeu samedi j'ai vu
quelque chose
un truc que je ferais touchant c'est que
parfois tu nous engueule dans les loges
parfois voilà quand il ya un truc que tu
ne supporte pas c'est quand d'autres le
font c'est qu'ils éventuellement toi un
jour nous traitait mal parce que tu es
de mauvaise humeur pourquoi pas mais si
c'est quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un
d'autre qui le fait pardon ça ça passe
pas et tu te pardonne pas donc à ce côté
voilà qui moi me touche beaucoup parce
qu'il sait que malgré tout à chaque fois
que j'ai besoin que j'ai eu besoin ou
que j'aurais besoin et même après les
pires engueulades tu seras là et stella
et donc ça ça me touche beaucoup
ça c'est fait c'est ce sera toujours
comme ça quand la question alors la
question si tu devais écoute bien sinon
toute ta famille brûle si tu devais non
parce qu'il ne fait pas de réponse à
l'algérie les chiris pape aussi michel
si tu devais absolument
ne gardez homme ou femme que deux
chroniqueurs dans cette émission à la
rochelle la saison seulement après sept
années passées un pas sur les dix ans
après ce que tu as vu cette année tu ne
te regarde et que deux la semaine
prochaine tous les autres poneys
renouveler qui te garde les deux mais je
prendrai les deux moins cher c'est sa
vie la vérité fondation chérie attention
non mais bon je ne devrais pas dire la
vérité à dire joua les deux moins cher
non les deux historiques dedans tu
pourras dire deux historiques pour
interdire de coeur tu joues énormes et
surprendre et les deux noms mais les
deux se nourrit les deux historiques et
de plus de plus anciens en bois je suis
obligée de garder de minces et isabelle
et jean qui est à isabelle janvier chez
jean louis bélanger que jean-luc non
mais sur les plus anciens et jean-michel
ça fait plaisir
parce que jean-luc voilà je les ai dans
mon avis c'est toujours avec moi la même
mais même à l'arizona raison messi ou à
l'année jean-michel déjà vu puisque
c'est les 2 plus faire voilà bravo